the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so anyway let's get started so the
first unit of the class so basically I'm
going to you know go over the first half
of a class today and the second half of
the class on Tuesday just because we
have to start somewhere so the first
things that we learnt about in this
class we're vectors and how to do dot
product of vectors so remember of a
formula that a dot B is the sum of AI
times bi and geometrically its length a
times length B times the cosine of the
angle between them and in particular we
can use this to detect when two vectors
are perpendicular that's when the other
product is zero and we can use that to
measure angles between vectors by
solving for cosine in this hopefully at
this point this looks a lot easier than
it used to a few months ago so hopefully
at this point everyone has this kind of
family memorized and has some reasonable
understanding of that but if you have
any questions now's the time no good
next we learned how to also do cross
product of vectors in space
and remember we saw how to use that to
find area of say a triangle or a
parallelogram in space because the
length of the cross product is equal to
the area of a parallelogram formed by
the vectors a and B and we can also use
that to find a vector perpendicular to
two given vectors a and B and so in
particular that comes in handy when we
are looking for the equation of a plane
because we've seen so the next topic
would be equations of planes and we've
seen that when you put the equation of a
plane in the form ax plus B y plus cz
equals D well ABC in there is actually
the normal vector to the plane lines
some normal vector to the plane so
typically we use cross product to find
plane equations okay is that still
reasonably familiar to everyone yes very
good
okay we've also seen how to look at
equations of lines and was aware of a
slightly different nature because we've
been doing them as parametric equations
so typically we had equations of a form
maybe X equals some constant plus some
constant times T y equals constant plus
constant times T Z equals constant plus
companies constant times T where this
comes here correspond to some point on
the line
and these coefficients here correspond
to a vector parallel to the 9 that's the
velocity of the moving point on the line
and well we've learned in particular how
to find where a line intersects a plane
by plugging in the parametric equation
into the equation of a plane we've
learned more general things about
parametric equations of curves so there
are these in famous problems in
particular where you have these rotating
wheels and points on them and you have
to figure out what's the position of a
point and the general principle of those
is that you want to decompose the
position vector into a sum of simpler
things okay so you know if you have a
point on a wheel that's itself moving on
something else then you might want to
first figure out the position of the
center of a wheel then find the angle by
which the wheel has turned and then get
to the position of a moving point by
adding together simpler vectors so the
general principle is really to try to
find one parameter that will let us
understand what has happened and then
decompose the motion into a sum of
simpler effect so we want to decompose a
position vector into some of simpler
vectors
okay so maybe now we are getting a bit
out of some people's comfort zone but
hopefully it's not too bad
do you have any general questions about
how would how one would go about that oh
yes sorry
what about parenting description of a
plane so we haven't really done that
because you would need two parameters to
parameterize a plane just because it's a
two-dimensional object so we have mostly
focused on the use of poetic equations
just for one-dimensional objects lines
and curves so you won't need to know
about parametric descriptions of planes
on the final but if you really wanted to
you know you would think of defining a
point on a plane as starting from some
given point then you have two vectors
given on the plane and then you would
add a multiple of each of these vectors
to your starting point but see the
difficulty is to convert from that to
the usual equation of a plane you'd
still have to go back to go back to this
cross-product method and so on
so it it is possible to represent a
planar internal surface in barometric
form but very often that's not so useful
yes
how do you parameterize an ellipse in
space well that depends on how it's
given to you but okay let's just do an
example say that I give you an ellipse
in space as you know maybe even more
well one exciting way to parameterize it
in editing space is maybe the
intersection of the cylinder with a
slanted plane that's the kind of
situations where you might end up with
an ellipse okay so if I tell you that
maybe I'm intersecting selling drunk
with equations x squared plus y squared
equals a squared with a slanted plane to
get off most of my picture to get this
ellipse of intersection so of course
you'd need the equation of a plane and
let's say that this plane is maybe given
to you or you can switch it to formula
where you can get to a form where you
can get Z as a function of x and y so
you know maybe it would be Z equals I
already used a I need to use some new
letter let's say C 1 X plus C 2 y plus D
what something like that so what I would
do is first I would look at what my
ellipse does in the directions in which
I understand it best and both directions
would be probably the XY plane so I
would look at the XY coordinates well if
I look at it from above XY my ellipse
looks like just a circle of radius a so
if I'm only concerned with X&Y
presumably I can just do it the usual
way for a circle x equals a cosine T y
equals a sine T okay and then Z would
end up being just well whatever the
value of Z is to be on the slanted plane
above a given X Y position so in fact it
would end up being a c1 cosine T plus a
c2 sine T plus D I guess
if it's not a particularly elegant
permit ization but that's the kind of
thing you might end up with now in
general when you have a curve in space
you know it would rarely be the case
that you have to get the parametrization
from scratch unless you're already being
told information about how it looks in
one of the coordinate planes you know
this kind of method or at least you know
you'd have a lot of information and that
would quickly reduce to a plane problem
somehow of course I could also just give
you some formulas and let you figure out
what's going on but in general you know
we've done knot stuff with plane curves
and with plane curve certainly those
interesting things with all sorts of
mechanical gadgets that we can study
okay any other questions on that okay so
let me move on a bit and point out that
with parametric equations we've looked
also at things like velocity and
acceleration so the velocity vector is
the derivative of the position vector
with respect to time and it's not to be
confused with speed which is the
magnitude of V so the velocity vector is
going to be always tangent to the curve
and its length will be the speed that's
the geometric interpretation
so just to provoke you I'm going to
write again that formula that was that V
equals t hat dsdt
what do I mean by that if I have a curve
and I'm moving on that curve well I have
the unit tangent vector which I think at
the time I used to draw in blue but blue
has been abolished since then so I'm
going to draw it in a head okay so
that's a unit vector that goes along the
curve and then the actual velocity is
going to be proportional to that and
what's the length well it's the speed
and the speed is how much arc length on
the curve I do per unit time which is
why I'm writing dsdt that's another guy
but another these guys for the speed
okay and we've also learned about
acceleration which is the derivative of
velocity so it's the second derivative
of a position vector and as an example
of the kinds of manipulations we can do
in class we've seen Kepler's second law
which explains how if the acceleration
is parallel to the position vector then
our cross V is going to be constant
which means that the motion will be in a
plane and you will sweep air at a
constant rate so now that is not in
itself a topic for the exam but the
kinds of methods of differentiating
vector quantities applying the product
rule to take the derivative of a dot or
cross product and so on are definitely
fair game I mean we've seen those on the
first exam they were there and most
likely they will be on the final
okay so I mean that's the extent to
which Kepler's law comes up only just
knowing the general type of
manipulations and proving things with
vector quantities but not again the
actual Kepler's law itself I skipped
something I skipped matrices the
dominants and linear systems okay so
we've seen how to multiply matrices on
how to write linear systems in matrix
form so remember if you have a 3x3
linear system in the usual sense so you
can write this in a matrix form where
you have a three by three matrix and you
have an unknown column vector and the
our matrix product would be some given
column vector okay so if you don't
remember how to multiply matrices please
look at the notes on that again and also
you should remember how to invert a
matrix so how did we invert matrices let
me just remind you very quickly so I
should say two by two or three by three
matrices well you need to have a square
matrix to be able to find an inverse the
method doesn't work doesn't make sense
otherwise then the concept of inverse
doesn't work and if it's larger than
three by three then we haven't seen that
so so let's say that I have a three by
three matrix
what I will do is I will start by
forming the matrix of my nose so
remember that my nose so each entry is a
2 by 2 determinant in the case of a 3 by
3 matrix formed by deleting one row and
one column okay so for example to get
the first minor as I said you know in
the upper left corner I would delete the
first row first column and I would be
left with this 2 by 2 determinant I take
this times that minus this time so that
I get a number that gives me my first
main oh and then same with the others
then I flip signs according to this
checkerboard pattern and that gives me
the matrix of cofactors ok so all it
means is I'm just changing the signs of
visible entries and leaving the others
alone and then I take the transpose of
that so that means I weighed it
horizontally and write it down
vertically I swept the holes and the
columns and then I divide by the inverse
well I divide by the determinant of the
initial matrix ok so of course this is
kind of very theoretical when I write it
like this
I mean power it makes more sense to it
an example I will let you work out
examples or you know burg your
recitation instructors so that they do
one on Monday if you want to see that
it's a fairly straightforward method you
just have to remember the steps but of
course there's one condition which is
that the determinant of the matrix has
to be nonzero so in fact we've seen that
Oh Destin when Bob left
we've seen that the matrix is invertible
[Applause]
exactly when it's determinant is not
zero and if that's the case then we can
solve the linear system ax equals B by
just setting x equals a inverse B that's
V going that's going to be the only
solution to our linear system otherwise
well
ax equals B has either no solution or
infinitely many solution solutions yes
the determinant of a matrix real quick
well I can do it that quickly unless I
stop moving my hands very quickly but so
remember we've seen that if you have a
matrix of three by three matrix its
determinant will be obtained by doing an
expansion with respect to what your
favorite but usually we are doing it
with respect to the first row so we take
this entry and multiply it by that
determinant then we take that entry
multiply it by that determinant but put
a minus sign and then we take that entry
and multiply it by this determinant here
and we put a plus sign for that okay so
maybe I should write it down that's
actually the same formula that we are
using for cross products all right when
we do cross products first we're doing
an expansion with respect to the first
row that's a special case okay I mean
you still want to see it more detail so
that okay yes
okay so if you do an expansion with
respect to any row or column then you
would use the same signs that are in the
curve that are in this checkerboard
pattern there so if you did an expansion
actually so indeed maybe I should say
the marginal way to the determinant is
you take your favorite form of column
and you just multiply the corresponding
entries by the corresponding cofactors
so the signs are plus or minus depending
on what's in that diagram there now in
practice in this class again all we need
is to do it with respect to the first
pole so don't you know don't worry about
it too much okay so again the way that
we've officially seen it in this class
is just if you have a 1 a 2 a 3 B 1 B 2
B 3 C 1 C 2 C 3 then so if determinant
is a 1 times B 2 B 3 C 2 C 3 minus a 2
b1 b3 c1 c3 plus a3 b1 b2 c1 c2 and this
minus is here basically because of the
minus in the diagram up there but that's
all we need to know yes
how do you tell the difference between
infinitely many solutions or no
solutions that's a very good question so
in full generality the answer is we
haven't quite seen a systematic method
so you just have to try solving and see
if you can find a solution or not so let
me actually explain that more carefully
so what happens to these two situations
when you know a is invertible or not so
remember in a linear system you can
think of a linear system as asking you
to find the intersection between three
planes because each equation is the
equation of a plane right so ax equals B
for a by 3 system means that X should be
in the intersection of a planes and then
we have two cases so the case where the
system is invertible corresponds to the
general situation where your fav lines
somehow all just intersect in one point
and then the situation we have a
determinant
that's one determinant is not 0 you get
just one point however sometimes it will
happen that all the planes are parallel
to the same direction so determinant a
equals 0 means the three planes are
parallel to the same vector and in fact
you can find that vector explicitly
because that vector has to be
perpendicular to all the normals so at
some point we so have a subtle things
about how to find the direction of this
line that's parallel to all the planes
so now this can happen either with all
three planes containing the same line
you know they can all pass for the same
axis oh it could be that they're somehow
shifted with respect to each other and
so
like look like this then the last one is
actually in front of that to see the
lines of intersections between two of
the planes so here they all pass for the
same line and here instead they
intersect in one line here one line here
one line there and there's no triple
intersection
so in general we haven't really seen how
to decide between these two cases
there's one important situation where we
have seen we must be in the first case
that's when we have a homogeneous system
so that means if the right-hand side is
zero then well x equals zero is always a
solution it's called the trivial
solution it's the obvious one if you
want so you know that you know and why
is that well that's because all of your
planes have to pass for the origin so
you must be in this case if you have a
non invertible system where the
right-hand side is zero so in that case
if the right-hand side is zero there's
two cases either the matrix is
invertible then the only solution is the
trivial one or if the matrix is not
invertible then you have infinitely many
solutions if B is not zero then we
haven't really seen how to decide we
just seen how to decide between one
solution or zero and a many but not how
to decide between these last two cases
yes
I think in principle you would be able
to but that's well that's a slightly
counterintuitive way of doing it I think
it would probably work well I let you
figure it out okay
let me move on to the second unit maybe
because we've seen a lot of stuff almost
a quick question before that okay
okay so what was the second part of it
that's about well hopefully you kind of
vaguely remember what it was about
functions of several variables and their
partial derivatives okay so the first
thing that we've seen is how to actually
view a function of two variables in
terms of its graph and let's contour
plot so just to remind you very quickly
I have a function of two variables x and
y then the graph will be just the
surface given by the equation z equals f
of XY so for each x and y i plot a point
at height given by the value of a
function and then the contour plot will
be the topographical map for this graph
it will tell us what are the various
levels in there so what it amounts to is
we slice the graph by horizontal planes
and we get a bunch of curves which are
the points at given height on the plot
and so we get all of these curves and
then we look at them from above and that
gives us this map
with a bunch of curves on it and each of
them has a number next to it which tells
us the value of a function there and
from that map we can of course tell
things about where we might be able to
find minima or Maxima of our function
and how it varies with respect to X or Y
or actually in any direction at a given
point so now the next thing that we've
learned about is partial derivatives so
for a function of two variables there
would be two of them there's f sub X
which is partial F partial X and F sub y
which is partial F partial Y and in
terms of the graph they correspond to
slicing by a plane that's parallel to
one of the coordinate planes so that we
either keep X constant or keep Y
constant and we look at the slope of a
graph to see the rate of change of F
with respect to one variable only when
we hold the other one constant and so
we've seen in particular how to use that
in various places but for example for
linear approximation we've seen that the
change in F is approximately equal to F
sub X times the change in X plus F sub y
times the change in Y so you can think
of F sub X and F sub y as telling you
how sensitive the value of F is to
changes in x and y so this linear
approximation also tells us about the
tangent plane to the graph
of in fact when we turn this into an
equality that would mean that we replace
F by the tangent plane with also learned
various ways Oh before I go and I should
say of course we've seen this also for
functions of three variables right so we
haven't seen how to plot them and we
don't really worry about that too much
but if you have function of three
variables you can do the same kinds of
manipulations
so we've learned about differentials and
chain holes which are a way of clipper
caging these partial derivatives right
so the differential is just by
definition this thing called DF which is
f sub x times DX plus F sub y and dy and
what we can do for what we can do with
it is just either plug values for
changes in X&Y and get approximation
formulas or we can look at this in a
situation where x and y will depend on
something else and we'll get chain rule
so for example if x is a function of t
time for example and so is y then we can
find the rate of change of f with
respect to t just by dividing this by dt
so we get DF DT equals F sub X DX DT
plus F sub y dy DT we can also get our
chain rules say if x and y depend on
more than one variable you know if you
have a change of variables for example x
and y are functions of to Vegas at you
call U and V then you can express DX and
dy in terms of D U and DV and plugging
into DF you will get the manner in which
F depends on U and V so that will give
you formulas for partial F partial u
partial F partial V we look just like
these guys except there's a lot of curly
D's instead of straight ones and use and
recent denominators okay so that lets us
understand rate of change we've also
seen yet another way to package the
partial derivatives into not a
differential but instead vector that's
the gradient vector and I'm sure it was
quite mysterious when we first saw it
but hopefully by now
well it should be less mysterious
okay so we've learned about the gradient
vector del F is a vector whose
components are just the partial
derivatives so if I have a function of
just two variables then it's just this
and so when observation that we've made
is that if you look at a contour plot of
your function you know so maybe your
function is 0 1 & 2 then the gradient
vector is always perpendicular to the
contour plot and always points towards
higher ground okay so the reason for
that was that if you take any direction
you can measure the directional
derivative which means the rate of
change of F in that direction
so even a unit vector U which represents
some direction so for example let's say
I decide that I want to go in this
direction and I ask myself how quickly
will F change if I start from here and I
start moving towards that direction well
the answer seems to be it will start to
increase a bit and maybe at some point
later on something else will happen but
at first it will increase so the
directional derivative is what we've
called DF by D s in the direction of
this unit vector and basically the only
thing we know to be able to compute it
the only thing we need is that it's the
dot product between the gradient and
this vector u hat
in particular the direction derivatives
in the direction of I hat or J hat are
just the usual partial derivatives
that's what you would expect okay and so
now you see that here if you try to go
in a direction that's perpendicular to
the gradient then the directional
derivative will be zero because you're
moving on
the level curve so the value doesn't
change okay questions about that yes
that yeah so let's see so indeed to see
to look at more recent things if you're
taking the flux through something given
by an equation so if you have a surface
given by an equation say F equals one so
say that you have a soft surface or here
a curve given by an equation f equals
constant then the normal vector to the
surface is given by taking the gradient
of F and that is in general not a unit
normal vector now if you wanted the unit
normal vector to compute flux then you
would just scale this guy down to unit
length okay so if you wanted a unit
normal that would be the gradient
divided by its length however for flux
but still have limited usefulness
because you would still need to know
about D s but remember we've seen a
formula for flux in terms of a non unit
normal vector and another n dot k DX dy
so indeed this is how you could actually
handle calculations of flux for pretty
much anything
any other questions about that okay so
let me continue with couple more things
we need to so we've seen how to do min
max problems in particular by looking at
critical points so critical points
remember other points where all the
partial derivatives are zero so if you
prefer that's where the gradient vector
is zero and we know how to decide using
the second derivative test whether a
critical point is going to be a local
min a local max power saddle point
actually we can't always quite this side
because remember we look at the second
partials and we compute this quantity a
C minus B squared and if it happens to
be zero then actually we can't conclude
but most of the time we can conclude
however it's not all we need to look for
an absolute global maximum or minimum
for that we also need to check the
boundary points or look at the behavior
of a function at infinity so we also
need to check the values of F at the
boundary of its domain of definition or
at infinity you know just to give you an
example from single variable calculus if
you're trying to find the minimum and
the maximum of f of x equals x squared
well you'll find quickly that the
minimum is at 0 where x squared is 0 if
you're looking for the maximum you
better not just look at the derivative
because you won't find it that way
however if you think for a second you'll
see that if X becomes very large then
the function increases to infinity and
really and similarly you know if you try
to find the minimum and the maximum
x squared when X varies only between 1 &
2 where you won't find the critical
point but you'll still find that the
smallest value of x squared is when X is
at 1 and the largest is at x equals 2
and all this business about boundaries
and infinity it's exactly the same stuff
but with more than one variable it's
just the story that may be the minimum
and the maximum are not quite visible
but they're at the edges of the domain
we are looking at and well in the last
three minutes I will just write down a
couple more things we've seen there so
how to do max-min problems with non
independent variables so if your
variables are related by some condition
G equals some constant so then we've
seen the method of LaGrange multipliers
okay and what this method says is that
we should solve the equation gradient F
equals some unknown scalar lambda times
the gradient G so that means each
partial you know F sub x equals lambda G
sub X and so on and of course we have to
keep in mind the constraint equation so
that we have the same number of
equations as the number of unknowns
because you have a new unknown here so
and the thing to remember is that you
have to be careful that the second
derivative test does not apply in this
situation
this is only in the case of independent
variables so if you want to know if
something is a maximum or minimum you
just have to use common sense or compare
the values of a function at the various
points you found yes will we actually
have to calculate well that depends on
what the problem asks you you know it
might ask you to just set up the
equation so it might ask you to solve
them
so in general solving might be difficult
but you know if it asks you to do it
when it means it shouldn't be too hard I
haven't written the final yet so I don't
know what it will be but you know might
be an easy one and the last thing we've
seen is constraint partial derivatives
so for example you know if you have a
relation between XY and Z which are
constrained to be a constant then the
notion of cultural F partial X takes
several meanings so just to remind you
very quickly
there's the formal partial partial F
partial x which means X varies y and z
are held constant and we forget the
constraint this is not compatible with
the constraint but we don't care so
that's the guy that we compute just from
the formula for F ignoring the
constraint and then we have the partial
F partial X with y held constant which
means y held constant x varies and now
we treat Z as a dependent variable it
varies with X and y according to
whatever is needed so that this contract
constraint keeps
link and similarly there's partial F
partial X with Z held constant which
means that now Y is the dependent
variable and the way in which we compute
V is we've seen two methods which I'm
not going to tell you now because
otherwise we'll be even more time but
we've seen two methods for computing
these based on either the chain rule or
on differentials solving and
substituting into differentials